okay max keen playing some guy good luck
actually he probably doesn't need luck
playing a London system Queen b6
interesting
I mean if Queens xb2 there's a force
draw line with York be one two a-one
what why is he going into this I'll take
a draw he's gonna play for a win
how is he gonna play for a win I'm down
to draw here's a six game win streak
I mean objectively it's a draw anyway
I'm pretty sure how do I offer a draw
game I can't offer I draw oh it doesn't
let me until move twenty is it gonna
accept three fold what's going on that's
so funny I don't know what's going on
here I mean if he gets a long time maybe
I'll play for a win
yeah it doesn't let you draw before move
twenty because it's arena kings I mean
how else do I play for a win though if I
wanted to play for a win maybe a three
Wow he's playing for a win that's so
funny okay I have to take this seriously
now there's no respect for me it takes
what's material Muppet Queen for
something you can take out of seven
this looks strong get the night f7f six
while I'm up time and material
97's acute move maybe it's too cute
explained 94 centralized
targeting f7
one playoff five soon stops me maybe g4g
five provoke some weaknesses Wow
feels like this should just be crushing
to take on you six maybe
let's play this first sneaky attack
now maybe it's time to take now let's
take
threatening me than one I assume I mean
I'm threatening two different mates in
one my queen is being so sneaky
please Queen g7 looks really nice it's
likely g7 threatening made in one
training the rook Knights will hang
everything's hanging for black yes the
defend mates I can take the rook
and now this is also some pin play this
move rook c7 coming
oops
I'll take it any way I can get it oh man
I've eaten acha that was rough like he
almost flagged me in the end their next
game oh yeah he really over pushed
though you're a Danny wizard gifting
subs or you're a wizard Danny thanks so
much man
adrenaline to calm down with tea almost
out of tea though